clear skies and smooth Waters it's been
a relatively quiet period in Thai
politics
but as those enjoying a sunny weekend on
the beach know this could be the Calm
before the storm
the general election is now set for May
this is a very important election it is
a chance for us to get a new
administration because people have been
suffering
our folks are important because we are
the people we are part of this nation so
it's all right
the generals who've ruled Thailand since
the military coup nine years ago may
look like they have everything under
control a military appointed up a house
and a constitution that they put in
place both favor their parties
but the blame for a poorly managed
pandemic and the rising cost of living
has fallen on their shoulders
when a protester tried to question the
prime minister at a recent rally she was
hustled out of sight but they still need
votes and the long arm of military
control May no longer be enough the
system is gamed and strictness no doubt
however
this election in 2023 the 2023 election
is still the most consequence
consequential of elections in Thailand's
contemporary political history and no
one is wasting any time in getting their
campaigns underway the election date
hasn't even been decided yet and still
thousands of people are attending
political rallies all over the country
ties it seems are very keen to get back
into the polling booth at this early
stage per Thai seems to be ahead in the
race with opinion polls suggesting it
might win up to 50 percent of the vote
parties Allied to ousted prime minister
tax in shinawa have won the popular vote
every year since 2001 but they haven't
been in power for nearly a decade
this year the shinwot name is back on
the ballot his daughter is in the
running for prime minister
would you think they'll let you take
power if you win will they let you take
power if you win
but Thai politics is colorful and
complicated
access at The Ballot Box might not be
enough Tony Chang Al Jazeera tombury
Eastern Thailand